Braman undisclosed location hi in the
Hollywood Hills it's time once again for
long shot till night party cruise [ __ ]
old people Disneyland and very special
guest Karen kill Gareth and now please
welcome the host of the longship Sean
we started oh thank you thank you thank
you good morning and welcome to the
longshot it is a podcast my name is
Shawn Connor I'm your host with me today
on the show it is the human Wade Piper
mr. Jamie Phalarope whoa I don't know
it's a it's a bird okay it's a bird it's
called the foul rope and you just knew I
knew it was a bird but I looked up
specifically to see that it was a Wade
Piper hmm did you know - Wade Piper was
I don't even know it away Piper is now
it's like a beach in the sand paper also
here on the show today on the hotel room
pillow all right let's start today
mm-hmm this segment that we like to call
checking in let's start with Amber all
right um on Thursday Rosh Hashanah
I was thank you um I went to Disneyland
and I know that I talked about going to
do that in July just like a few weeks
ago right in July in mid-july
um but I went for like that work event
and it just with that ugly broad
disgusting okay um but it just made me
it like made me want to go back with
people I enjoy being around and it and
they you can take a looking at for more
than five seconds
but my boyfriend Jeff and I it was sort
of our anniversary it's sort of hard to
calculate at this point cuz we took that
year off oh I'm aware but that's where
we used to celebrate our anniversary so
we're just picking it back up he hadn't
been to Disneyland in a really long time
the last time was with me probably two
maybe three it was first on before it
was off and then back on it correct all
right it's not the craziest thing in the
world it happened sure but that time
that we went I was really really sick
but we had planned it so far in advance
that I just was a trooper and a champion
but I just can't if you may say so
yourself
well I was because like the next I was
like oh I was really sick and he's like
I had no idea I just thought you enjoyed
those boring shows where we got to sit
down and like getting some more water
and sit in the shade sounds fun huh
mm-hmm but I was just miserable but I
was trying to have a good time you
didn't let your misery show right
I've also this is tangent but it's
related I'm working on that I feel about
being honest with your feelings
yeah honoring yourself well also I
always thought that that was me being
nice but if people don't know that I'm
miserable that's not fair to them well
it's not fair to them especially a few
and I don't know that you feel this way
especially if you sometimes might resent
those people yeah yeah and I don't I
don't actively do that all the time but
it happens right sure you're human
beings and also yeah I mean I'm a human
being to finally say that so we went on
Thursday and it was the best I think it
might be the best time I've ever been to
Disneyland just the two of you just the
two of us um also sidenote strange
first time I paid to go to Disneyland
and probably think what's her secret
years well I worked I feel like they
would shoot you we have snipers um no I
worked there so I got in for free for so
long and then I knew so many people who
worked there but I
could have tried harder to try to get in
for free again but there's also the
thing where you feel obligated like I
just didn't want to owe anyone anything
and 15 years paying once I feel like
that's a good deal still I agree
especially have you've been more than
once
yeah I've been way more than once can
you bring a coke can get like 20 bucks
off
that's like Magic Mountain alright but
so what were the fun things you did well
we we got a park hopper so we went to
both parks we started off in California
adventure because Disneyland was open
later to start getting more magical
exactly and it was it was it was just
the best there was no real line to
California Adventure we hit some lines
in Disneyland but we still had a really
good time but I will say this last time
I went to Disneyland I complained on
this podcast about everyone taking
selfies on their iPads on rides on their
iPads yeah not even on their phone yeah
yeah it was really really really
annoying less of that happening so I
don't know what happened in the cultural
shift two months but there was less of
that somebody listened to the show and
they were like we got to discourage this
was it like senior citizens day no no I
I don't know what it was it bring your
kid to work day
no no it's Rosh Hashanah is Rosh
Hashanah okay so a lot of Jews there to
celebrate or a lot of joy is not there
are we saying that Jews like to take
selfies with iPads or they don't like to
I'm not saying anything all right go on
except and this is the big except we
went on the hunted mansion ride and
that's a dark ride that's the point yeah
and you're in a little cart very close
to the other little carts and there is a
rides work sure I think we're all
familiar with the concept but it also
like spins it it'll be facing the right
to show you the cool things here and
then the front and then the back
point is you get glimpses of the carts
next to you because you're spinning hey
it's those guys yeah the girls in front
of us
- like preteens were just taking flash
photography of everything and it would
be one thing if they were taking
pictures like wow this is so exciting I
have to take a bit like they looked
bored they looked like it was just this
is what I do I take pictures it was just
robotic I only like to cut the preteen
some slack because they don't know
anything right that's always been John
Stan something you love slack of all the
people in the world I cut the most slack
routines but it got to the point because
Jeff is more grumpy old man than most
people for being a young man and he
finally was like stop doing that your
kids and I thought that was funny
because they looked at him like the
thing about pretty teens is they're not
gonna they're not going to hear you say
that and say wow you know that's a
really good thinking if I was a preteen
and somebody said that to me I would've
been like [ __ ] you though but see I'm so
on board with the brief you know what
cause of all the slack I cut them so
much slack and I have the same response
but the part that killed me is like this
is a little bit of a spoiler if you
haven't been on the Haunted Mansion ride
if not you only had 60 years to do it or
what it's been open forever oh but I am
gonna live that long and how you're
implying that he was 60 years old that's
what it sounded like oh that's not what
I meant okay what at the very end it
looks like one of the ghosts is
hitchhiking into your little cart that's
a new parts that they use for rides the
word cart I think cart and that's not
definite not a car it's car carriage I
think is right I think it's vehicle sled
cart was weird but anyway bobsled this
they make it look you look in a mirror
and you
see yourselves but you also see one of
those ghosts sitting between you and
it's very spooky but it's a mirror and
there's no such thing as ghosts
easy I wouldn't don't things you can't
take back shocker
these girls were taking flash pictures
of the mirror cut them some slack know
how light works they haven't studied
light in science yet reflective sir it's
just a circle of white light has anyone
changed after I took chemistry I feel
like it would be less is chemistry where
you learned about light I had a terrible
teacher terrible I did quite well but it
was really fun we stayed till it closed
hot tip for those of you going to
Disneyland I mean time soon after the
park closes main street is always still
open an hour after the park closes
because they want you to buy [ __ ] and
it's a commercial enterprise - outside
of Disney and they have those tiles
where you could say like the Conroy
family and a year I don't know but you
can buy my family was there I'm trying
to cut you some slack
there's tiles out like on the grounds
right and you can buy one and it could
say your name you and your husband's
name it could have like Mickey Mouse the
point is it it looks like something you
would do for a charity oh man
so you go into a little stand and you
say I want to put me and my husband's
name on a tile up front does it happen
right then or do you have to come back
and see it a year later I don't I don't
know I've never done it it's a brick on
the ground I'm this is this has been the
most confusing part of the show what do
you put Shaun flam Conroy I'm just
thinking it as the concept is the
funniest thing in the world
is this a proposal episode let's see
where we I can't wait but but yes [ __ ]
you so hard only vote callbacks anyway
we stayed an hour after the park closed
it was really really cute like Jeff was
like a little kid like he just kept
being like let's look at that well I hit
an old man with the same thing yeah yeah
yeah this don't feel like like in 1930s
Main Street kind of vibe it's got like
crystals and stuff mmm blinking lights
mmm I love that and everything was
pumpkiny because it's fall everything
almost borderline too many pumpkins but
but yeah he he's he likes baby stuff but
he doesn't like babies that's such a
silly sell sexy contradiction but yeah
but it was like a little kid I couldn't
drag him home I thought he'd be like
let's go model dinner he's like I don't
want to go but it was really fun and
yeah you highly recommend it mm-hmm
you're a corporate shill Jamie buy one
of those bricks what's going on with you
I just got back from June Lake
where's June link June Lake is up north
it's by a mammoth it's in the middle of
the state you got a mammoth lakes he had
June Lake some other Lakes Mono Lake is
kind of the big one
the Owens Valley I feel like you would
know a lot about no no plays a big role
I actually I actually watched the movie
most of it I fell asleep by ringing
endorsement
it's a classic mood with Jack Nicholson
Easy Rider no takes place in the 30s I'm
shining Chinatown Chinatown yes which
was so relevant it bothers me a that you
fell asleep you couldn't think of the
name of the movie I think the most
famous movie of all have you seen it
it's a great movie I've seen multiple
times it's Chinatown yeah I watched like
three-quarters of it and then it was
late you know the end is work that's
kind of interesting I know I was hoping
it doesn't move super quick Oh James
balloons Valley was where the water
where the water comes from yeah that's
kind of where we went and was a Humphrey
Bogart movie it took place in Casablanca
I don't remember the name of it played
against Sam's
what happened Jim Lake Jamie well on
Saturday we went to a ghost sound
speaking of ghosts called Lodi called
what bode spell d bo d IE although as I
learned it had a different spelling bo d
ey I think perhaps you seem like you're
an expert on bode
anyway bode was a at its height in like
1880 1889 T what remains is 5% of all
the buildings that were there 10,000
people lived there at its peak and it
was a crazy town they said there were
gunshots fired every day and people were
killed and hung and there was a mining
town and why did everyone leave what
happened
welcome to the worst tour guide ever
over here we have an old building of
some kind
this again is 5% of 10,000 builds for
some sort of structure so what happened
while you were there well first of all
it started snowing it was freezing Wow
it was cold that's crazy so it also like
in that pamphlet that the weirdest
flurry motor so you were you dressed for
the weather or were you caught unawares
yes I kind of like double speak double
PluralEyes pamphlet Viki you know for
two dollars that they make you buy like
a pamphlet when you when you get in
there okay so you got the pamphlet I did
it won't mention that though the weather
was terrible it was like known for
having terribly there's no reason to
move there it seemed like a terrible
place to go what was a gold-mining town
right I think they just missed the gold
mining boom
but some sort of other money thing I
know we're a little late guys but let's
move here but getting going and I went
there as a kid too and I remember like
the the road to get up there is so bumpy
and it was no different it was like the
craziest bumpy road to get there and so
like the street in front of my house
where's your street is paved it's
terrible really not almost
oh it's awful yeah it's embarrassment
then we go on if you're listening mr.
mayor I'd like something done about that
go ahead the meet the mayor the mere
like mayor yeah your time up mayor's the
mayor um I commented on someone's posts
on Instagram today and made a reference
to the Red Hot Chili Peppers song under
the bridge
fun fact okay I was back to your story
about the ghost town so the ghost town
was cool and also great a third
adjective Lord oh but I decided I
figured out my um my first period piece
comedy it's going to take place alone
it's gonna be Western asking about a
couple that travel from the east coast
it's a nebbishy jew and he's but he's
stuck in Bodie in 1890 they go there to
get away he's gonna write his book and
all the adventures between him and his
wife he's gonna write his book he's we
want to escape the East Coast whatever
rich places from so it is kind of like
The Shining well it's the shining bit
more wacky right yeah well yeah this is
your young comedy is Johnny by the way
Joe Wagner like called me out on Twitter
I saw that like it's like the craziest
thing ever that I would write a period
piece comedy yeah I I believe I
favorited that - I believe I saw that I
cannot wait to prove you all wrong dude
but others some of our fans I think he
just got a kick out of you talking about
that well I'll give you think of
the hubris involved of sitting here and
going I'm gonna have a career just like
Mel Mel Mel Brooks you know I've always
said hubris am i robbers hmm um no I
think there's different ways to say it
and some of them are more humorous than
others
so what else Jamie anyway it was a fun
trip was a good getaway on Saturday
night we were all cooking there was like
seven of us rate of us and just in the
kitchen and it was cleanup time LaVette
what like I love the group looking
dinner together I really do place was
amazing it was a three-story some TV
executives place above June Lake like
what this beautiful view and just what
he'd be executive how did that happen I
don't know but she did a lot of VHS
tapes including in the Hendersons yeah
I'm pretty sure that area in ursins um
so
oh yeah it's sort of cleaning up and at
some point like I went to the help clean
up and someone's like whoa look Jamie's
open I was like wait what do you mean
and like well yeah I mean yeah you know
you're pretty lazy and I'm like what do
you mean I'm pretty lazy like I mean
sometimes I'm lazy I'm kind of lazy my
career and it's taking me a long time to
get to where I want but am i known for
being lazy and she was like well kinda
that's kind of your thing oh you like to
nap a lot me like and so we got the
whole thing we're like at least this
group of people find me to be a lazy
human being and I was sorry what is that
because you don't usually help clean up
no I try to help I don't like to think
that I don't help clean up
mmm-hmm I'll do some dishes but I guess
what I'm saying is what are they basing
their evaluation on I think it's mostly
cleanup situations
anyway I had to reevaluate like and now
you're gonna be very focused on pitching
in yeah more so I don't want to be known
as a lazy guy we'll see what happens
because this place is usually trashed
after you guys leave like there's cops
everywhere
you called us out me it has not improved
I also feel like well this is
my own thing but let's talk about me for
a minute
um I come from a big family and
everybody wants to impress everybody
else and now everybody has wives and
husbands and children and all those
people want to impress everybody else so
there's always a scurry to be the first
person to clean up clear the table or
clean up or set the table or whatever
and I don't like I'm like okay great if
you just want to do it go ahead you know
and so I think they think that I'm lazy
but it's like I'm not being lazy I'm
just not gonna fight you for the
opportunity to carve the meat or
whatever you might be like more human
you're not like me please but also it's
like let's enjoy like oh so quick to
clean up let's just enjoy just because
you started clean everything mean I have
to start cleaning up well by the way
already have to leave early I can't help
clean up tonight I think you should be
less lazy thanks but it sucks when you
discover how people see you in a way
that you did not alright well this feels
like a good place to take a break I have
lots to check in with but we have a hard
out tonight so well I'll save it till
next time I'll keep a list on my phone
so we will back in a moment with a very
special guest
Haverhill mrs. Jamie flam from the
longshots podcast which you are
currently tuned into and listening to on
some sort of device that was built for
the amplification of sound how cool is
that
I love sound amplification one of my
favorite things anyway thanks for tuning
in we love having great listeners like
you if you want to read more about what
we got going on and get access to
upcoming episodes join us online at the
longshot podcast.com we're also on
Facebook
we got a Facebook group and a Facebook
page do a search for us on Facebook I'm
sure we'll come up Twitter at long shot
podcast and of course we're on iTunes
and bunch of other weird sites that kind
of exists in some way where they take
existing websites and funnel their
information through I do a web search
I'm sure some of those will come up and
also from libsyn we're part of the all
things comedy network run stitcher
and we love you very much may your day
or evening or morning be enchanted and
magical Shawn told me to say that and
enjoy the rest I love you
we are back you are listening to the
long shot
it is a podcast hopefully you're aware
of that and you're not just going what's
happening right now our special guest
today is none other than the hilarious
Karen killed your hello thank you so
much for being it's my pleasure and you
said you used to live right in this
neighborhood right I live down should
I'd be very vague about names and
numbers so that no one comes we're we we
say that we are broadcasting from an
undisclosed location high in the
Hollywood Hills but I think there are a
lot of people who know actually we got
through we had to go through two didn't
wait I had to call in a secret number
ya know it's and talk to this you
checked your passport at the door right
yeah yeah they took all of my ID and my
gun no I used to live directly below the
main cross street down there seven years
I lived in the south of Franklin on
grace about the franklin andre google
map at everybody the grace apartments
and studio apartment with a cat which is
basically like living in a litter box um
young just made it happen for myself
down there it's pretty great so i have a
lot of it's um it's just nice to be back
what's good to have you back and that
actually leads very well into what we
wanted to talk about today we always
have a theme on the show and today we
decided we would talk about neighborhood
interactive so let's start today in a
way that we rarely do and let's go first
to Jamie Oh first to me guys Wow let's
talk about my neighborhood interactions
I live in an area called Fairfax I feel
like it's just easier for me when I have
like kind of a thesis statement mm-hmm
what's your thesis statement not I live
in Fairfax
I guess my thesis statement is oh the
people I meet
or so your thesis statement is ripping
off dr. Seuss well it's just an
exclamation it's not the people I meet
in my neighborhood sure are interesting
groundbreaking I guess sure all right
this could be published we could
transcribe this it's actually not even
inaccurate there are some interesting
people I mean my neighborhood such as
the people that work at the kombucha and
breakfast
you have no specifics they love to talk
about that wait that kombucha is oh no
although I've been seen more and more of
those people around any of them have an
eyepatch dad no are they out by nose
there's literally a guy there's nothing
interesting about them there's a guy
that lives in my neighborhood
I've seen him taking a [ __ ] [ __ ] into
a bag I really like it that is so
interesting but he also like basically
lives in the bus stop at Fairfax and
Melrose sits in there all day
today as I was passing him to put some
mail in the mailbox because I had to 70s
probably just chopping off his hair
[ __ ] in bags
that's an interesting character in there
there sure are some interesting people
in your neighborhood well we were
talking about earlier I live in this
weird neighborhood which is kind of like
where Orthodox Jews and youth hip-hop
skate culture converge is that a thing
Youth hip hop skate culture okay which
if I when I was 16 that's what I would
have wanted to be mm-hmm well you would
have wanted to be anything when you were
16 that's true you tried a little bit of
everything right
but it's like I would actually go to
that neighborhood interesting I don't
know about for you guys but when I was
in high school like the skaters were one
section and hip-hop people were not like
they didn't there weren't a lot of and
the youths were third yes but so I like
that they've married a little
because they used to like the Steve
getting some marriage today whatever the
mesquite kids were really into like punk
I guess that's what whatever I felt when
I was a kid when I was 16 years old they
all were the same thing like I wanted to
be a raver a tagger a gang member a hip
hopper to me they're all the same thing
it was all kind of like you know called
cooler than what you were in real life I
mean I wore some pretty big pants size
48 orange corduroy at one point slacks
you cut yourself some slack I was
talking about with some yesterday and
they would like I'm gonna keep working
that you didn't him closing so dragging
around her did you wear those shoes that
with the really big soles like crazy
platform
no never platform I never even actually
went to a rave what were you doing with
those pants then I'm just thinking that
I was something oh I don't know he was
desperately trying to fit in yeah yeah
we all experienced we're clowns it was a
very cloudy time people like were like
huge shirts with like the Charlie Brown
thing like 1993 oh yeah yeah yeah it was
like a big cartoon character kind of
things oh it was like Elmo or like
Grover Tasmanian Devil but in Raiders
gear or is that a different thing no
there's definitely those that piss me
off like Tweety Bird with a stupid like
sideways hat and like trying to be like
[ __ ] down 90s was a weird era for the
clothing yeah I remember getting to high
school and in my mind if you were and
party crews were thing it did it was
like you know kids they like would
associated with other people they
enjoyed each other's company I think it
was an LA thing in the late 90s but I
wanted to be in a party crew
I remember talk you know Jamie I got bad
news you can't be in our party crew
party no you're not in a party crew I
want the application process for the
party I honestly pictured like the
meetings of the party crews and the
tagging gangs of like almost like that
80s movie style thing we're being a cave
and like there'd be like some guy at the
top like like pinball machines
everywhere and someone skateboarding oh
no police academy - is that the mold
Bobcat go away he was all of them oh
really there was one where he kind of
led like the king of bad boys kind of a
party group but they they would like go
into like grocery stores and like
[ __ ] wreak havoc I feel like you were
delusional and I wish that there had
been a way for someone to just take you
by the shoulders and look deeply into
your eyes sixteen-year-old Jamie's eyes
and go you're okay
it's okay I feel like that would have
helped you and I also get the feeling
and you could correct me if I'm wrong
but you are a very good kid fantasizing
about being a rebel totally I had you
know middle class I say like we're a
rule follower - nobody was really big
through nachos on somebody at a
basketball no I had my bed my bed was
the baddest thing you did nachos on
something I started transcribing my
diary you know I've read my diary at
this mortified show for years but that's
just like scratching the surface I've
started transcribing it I think I have a
book guys do it a [ __ ] neck which
comes first the book or the well Brooke
style do not focus just put everything
out there right right with each hand let
it all come out right brain left brain I
don't know what's gonna hit first guys
but it's gonna open up a lot of doors
and we're all going to the top together
I just have to say I've been - Bodie
that's why I put my hand up when you
start talking about it because it's one
of the most boring places I've ever been
talking about it I really recreated the
boredom of the place what did you get
out of it that I didn't it was like a
one Street strip of abandoned buildings
and
little train right it's the same place
like it was B there's a gap well it was
probably five years ago works okay so
because I went there was a kid and it
was so much bigger than I remember it
like it's Grievous boring and it's cold
when it's snowing and you're like what
the [ __ ] and but for me that I talked
about it because of this [ __ ] movie I
do it's burned something that makes
sense I didn't know you raised your hand
and that makes a lot more sense
he just kept pointing to you every time
he mentioned on every conversation I
just sit over there while you guys grab
I'm like super sting at the seams of
like I know what you're talking about
narcissus I assume that everyone's in my
brain at all times too
it didn't occur to me that I was doing
anything weird no I just missed that one
connector between I was in fourth grade
so I thought he was just like Jamie tell
us about some people in your
neighborhood okay I was just gonna talk
about there's so many skaters the
[ __ ] he does it all the time now he
doesn't open his mouth without saying
the word [ __ ] I swear I'm not gonna
say it again are you trying to get into
a party crew oh good way to get in their
good graces I bet um so so what happened
so these skating kids and I'm just gonna
sound like such an old [ __ ] man but
they have no respect thank you
they have no respect for their elders is
skating kids have no respect when it'll
teach them of lesson by the way yeah we
are both complaining about teenagers
alright I believe that one of the great
myths along with like the Loch Ness
monster and all this kind of [ __ ] is
that someone has actually ever
successfully landed a skateboarding
trick those videos are free you don't
have YouTube or
walk the streets for 37 years now and
I've at one point you know as friends
with skaters and like yeah I watch them
just do these tricks never once if I
seen them actually land a trick it's
always like oh [ __ ] dude instead of like
[ __ ] yeah dude I want to see one [ __ ]
yeah dude not well I think you have to
fail numerous times before you succeed
good advice for life by the way but I'm
like when I'm walking down the street at
least if you're gonna skate in front of
me and like do a weird flip thing oh no
I feel like it's also just a mode of
transportation the mode of
transportation thing find great skate
along itself is very impressive when you
see someone like just I always look at
that of like if that was me I would stop
short or like have to stick my foot down
or the guys that can actually like
serpentine between people and not be
that those are the people that are
really good no and I think that's fine
when they're not get those [ __ ] going
with the flow but there's [ __ ] these
[ __ ] skaters man [ __ ] god bless
these [ __ ] kids but they're in the
middle of everything
and I was walking down Melrose last week
last Monday and these two guys three
guys we're doing their tricks that one
of the skateboards flies in the middle
of the street on Melrose like two cars
almost hit each other because they had
to stop because this thing goes flying
in the street if they hit each other to
get out of the way of a skateboard they
would have been [ __ ] idiots yeah well
you I want to react it like that we just
see this thing kind of fly out and the
kids like going running after a dog or a
baby or like you just really flat baby
they're all this crab baby baby impress
me and then the kid that runs on the
street gets in the cars stopping like
almost like I heard something like do
like a sorry man
or girl or whatever and instead of just
like you just kind of like [ __ ] you
teenagers are like that happened right
in front of me and then they start
skating right for me as I'm walking
continuing to walk and like I know this
guy's gonna [ __ ] up his whatever trick
he's trying to do and it's gonna go
flying at me what a sour worldview you
have I know I'm the most positive guy in
the world I know that's kind of one of
my things I'm lazy your point of view
isn't like skateboarders should not be
skating that they should be landing like
there's so many streets in this city
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of streets in LA don't skate on Melrose
and Fairfax that's exactly like like a
skateboarding Mecca but I came out with
your buddies don't like you be doing
trying to do tricks that are never gonna
work but how are you ever gonna learn
the tricks if you don't keep trying D
parks now and there's like abandoned
warehouses Jamie wants kids to houses
abandoned anything yeah there's nothing
you can do sounds oh my god you imagine
tons of great skateboarders in Bodhi you
would go crazy I'll wear a little cowboy
green we're gonna move you could you
write about that I'm gonna mix this
world the party crew goes to boating
with their [ __ ] skateboards Bugsy
Town be town what can i scope quick
sidebar question salut you talked about
that there are snipers at Disneyland and
you just you just threw that out and
then no one said anything about it and
is it true are you joking interesting I
find snipers boring I don't believe that
distracts people that are interested in
comments thank you back and sighs I
don't think they're actual snipers but I
do feel of their people watching every
movie but they're not ready are there
security guards they will like like tase
you maybe but not oh no it definitely
won't let anything bad go there are very
few assassinations that happen right I
just know we know I feel like camo
I do think that exists I do maybe there
are I actually think that because
they're so protective of that brand it's
true that's going too far though now
there's some book I read that was like
in when they first opened the park that
there was like a guy that died of a
heart attack because they took him so
far out of the way to make sure no
people in the park saw you know an
ambulance or anything like all that kind
of stuff that they do for the machine
it's a real deal thing that even if
somebody dies they will scoot them off
the property so that they before they're
pronounced dead so that they're not
pronounced dead at diseases yeah how
they came up with the original idea for
weekend at Bernie the coaster but they
have to be two steps ahead of you and
you need precision thinking and the mind
of the snipers we were talking about
people in your neighborhood and now
we're talking with the precision mind of
a sniper
anyways skateboarders go [ __ ] yourself
just kidding my god bless you keep doing
your sport I appreciate what you do
angry stand
you are completely wishy-washy well cuz
I want the skateboarders like when my
[ __ ] movie about Bodhi comes out you
can't people [ __ ] gun see my [ __ ]
movie alright sorry I totally derailed
that that was no tell us about who are
the people in your neighborhood in my
neighborhood I live over in Burbank kind
of I didn't say I never thought about
stuff like this I'm not until I got my
podcast and we said somebody's something
out loud and then it was like we are so
paranoid about details right don't
necessary at all but anyway in my
neighborhood it's kind I live I'm
basically like Toluca Lake adjey
so I don't live in Toluca Lake we're all
the richie-rich fancy houses are but I'm
kind of near it so I walk my dog in
Toluca Lake cuz it's a way better walk
in the morning mm-hm and of course there
are just old rich people that have lived
there forever and I'm sure a lot of them
are like don't you know me I'm I'm that
person that's from st. elsewhere or
whatever there's there's a tangible
bitterness I was on fish Vigoda snow
fish Oh spin-off of Barney Miller Oh
Cagney and Lacey seems like all right we
could go all day references I mean it's
such a great time TV time for cops so
anyway I was walking walk my dogs - dogs
and I am a very very hyper conscious dog
walker because I really hate people that
just let dog [ __ ] sit on the street I've
watched tons of people in front of my
house just let their dog [ __ ] on my lawn
and walk away it's I think it's so
irresponsible and hideous it's gross
it's so gross it's just it's like this
is them it's your dogs you have to do it
it's ridiculous
I think that's worse than skateboarders
thank you I do that's a good thesis
you've come down on the right side so
anyway I'm very aware of it and I'm
aware of it down to the point of where I
throw the garbage I almost never throw a
very carefully tied up bag of dog [ __ ]
that's scented into an empty garbage can
which means it just got empty because
then that means it sits there for a full
week and you sense it yourself business
it's Chanel number five I want them to
remember me not the dog so on this one
morning I was wearing my iPod and there
was all the garbage cans were out on
both sides of the street which usually
they only are picking up one side so I
wasn't really paying attention and I was
holding a bag of dog [ __ ] for a long
time being conscientious and I finally
came up to my first garbage can opened
it there was a garbage bag at the bottom
through my dog bag dog [ __ ] in kept
walking saw something in the corner of
my eye turn and look and there's an old
lady coming across the street at me
they're finger waving in the air me mmm
at her mouth is moving and in my ears
it's like the jam is clean but it's her
yelling at me so I pull out my ear
earbud and I was like excuse me ma'am I
didn't hear what he said he was like
that's not your garbage can you can't
use that garbage can that's it that's
private property and you can't throw
that in there and did it and I was like
and I just let her go because normally
I'm very reactive person I have a lot of
rage and kind of standard irish-catholic
[ __ ] going on inside all the time
welcome to the club right you just want
to teach everybody a lesson and you have
a lesson to teach situation so and I can
been waitin for this one for a while
because it's like no I'm the one that
does pick up the dog [ __ ] I'm not the
one you yell at so as I and also I don't
like old people I think I just don't
like old people because they boy every
age is taken in in the neck to make sure
go to hell all of you those middle-aged
but it was it's just that thing of like
when old people they turned bitter and
it's like they're they've decided to
close themselves off or something and
they just want they pretend the world is
theirs to control and especially rich
people so and their face is sort of
frozen in a frown
yes it's either your happy old person
person cuz you're doing it right or
you're one of these people that comes at
with the finger leading which is like I
wanted to snap that thing off I was just
like what you Deli could have done was
very curled over she actually wasn't
that old but she was just had that thing
and I was looking at Hollywood and I
made a decision which in the past I've
never been able to make a choice before
I usually just start yelling immediately
it's like a weird family thing where if
you start yelling at me I'll just yell
louder and faster and just beat you at
Rage so I was like nope no we're not
doing that I let her yell and yell and
yell about how it's a private garbage
can that all the neighborhood talks
about how we're sick of these dog people
you can't just throw those bags of [ __ ]
everywhere which I agree with right and
that's not what I was doing but I was
just kind of letting her run it out and
then when she said private garbage can
just this kind of like lincoln-douglas
debate or dinged up in my head where I
just went you know these are public
these are publicly owned at I pointed at
like LA City on the front of the garbage
can and it just pissed her off even more
and I actually was like ma'am I walk my
dogs all the time
I'm very conscientious I opened that
garbage can there was a bag at the
bottom I assumed it was sitting out for
garbage day went through the whole
scientific rationale yeah you disposed
of dog [ __ ] how you dispose of it as a
conscientious dog owner who gives a [ __ ]
about their neighborhood and community
and I said and I live very close to you
and I've been doing this for a long time
I'm I don't know who you're talking
about but I'm not the enemy or whatever
and then she was like you people do it
all the time whatever and then I waited
legal is always a yes finger at me and
the you people
I waited you white Irish cat always
trying to teach lesson so then I had to
teach her a lesson cuz she wouldn't stop
and I did I tried to be polite and then
so I smiled at her and I said ma'am I
think you're mad about something else
and she started laughing it pissed her
off so bad she started laughing that's a
good man I was yeah because and then she
said well I guess you're just
inconsiderate then and then that's when
I lost it because I was like you're just
you won't stop you're like the [ __ ]
terminator of old ladies and so he said
well I guess you're the most polite
person in the world and then I turned
around and walked away and that kind of
stopped her cuz it's like I just it's
like I've lived near this woman for 10
years she's never said a word to me and
then the one time she chooses to see
yelling that it wasn't even to say
excuse me could you not do that because
we don't like it and it makes the
garbage anything normal it was like as
if she's gonna you people with your
stuff where it's like you know dog [ __ ]
you dog [ __ ] people spreading your dog
[ __ ] everywhere and is it just a smell
thing is that what they don't like well
here's what I also was gonna say like
what do you care it's a garbage can and
also if you care so much about the way
your garbage can smells then pull it in
when it's
garbage and this is a Chanel number five
[ __ ] bag by me all lavender yeah
because her garbage can right nope
and like I don't know I just it's
controlling its old rich people who
think who have nothing else to complain
right and so they think they can control
you or every single thing about the
world and I'm sure she's got her like
path to Trader Joe's down pat and
everything right she's a [ __ ] to all
the people that she needs to be a [ __ ]
to everyday right and so this was just a
thing of like oh I don't like this and
you are now the face of it and the
representative of it I guess I also fail
to see the logic because here's somebody
who is cleaning up like in other words
you know I guess it's not would you
rather I just leave the dog [ __ ] on the
street but it kind of is because there
are people that do it so it's like I'm
not leaving on the street and I'm not
like just throwing the bag somewhere
which I've seen people do that too it's
like I'm actually putting garbage in a
garbage can is what I'm doing at the end
of the day what's that the people that
don't put it in a trash can where they
put it no I've seen bags they just like
there are people that are so
inconsiderate so she's basically I don't
know it just really pissed me and also I
always think about this when somebody is
reacting that way like what is her
fantasy like what would be the end game
that would be perfect in her head for
you dogs fall to your knees and
apologize and then like go to shoot well
I did do I think she wants a
three-picture deal at Warner Brothers
and since that all ended in 48 her only
thing left is this I actually I went
home and wrote her a stern letter that
of course because I was I started the
letter with hey now I know where you
live like it was that kind of thing of
like don't but then I just realized I
was just too mad right and I don't like
getting yelled at by old people and
right makes me extra I don't like
getting yelled out by anybody
yeah it's up because I deal with a lot
of old people complaining at work and
it's most of the time I ration is just
like who cares like it must be so nice
that zero problems that your soaps
at about this but to see it from the
other point of view I do catch myself in
weird ways having those like social
justice flare-ups like if I'm standing
in a line and I see somebody cutting in
line and it doesn't even affect me like
I feel my body tense like yes I could I
see how that is the root of me as an old
lady sticking my finger in someone's
face like it's that's the beginning but
I tamper a temper temper
bumper I you temper it all no no what's
a good way for me as a
passive-aggressive cool man I use it a
lot everybody gets you when you do that
I'm sure oh that I mean that's the way
to deal with it when people actually
make you mad but I guess my thing was
like I saw it happening and I was like
just don't don't be a part of this like
you have plenty problems in your life
like you don't need being mad at this
old lady but she wouldn't stop coming at
me and she was so indignant I think also
I'm from Northern California we were
born and raised to hate people from
Southern California as you hang with
them yes there's not all people it's
this very specific it's like these
people who live in you badly
who hang a tennis ball in their garage
so that they pull their you know BMW in
just perfectly but you know [ __ ] that's
a great idea
yeah like the midgets like this weird
it's this weird way of living that they
use for my Wilson thing that if you were
out of my party crew if you had laid
into that levy you would just feed into
her like see she is a monster I was
right Bubba Baker up and pumpkin bread
and dental fillings but right in the
last fight there's a bag
all right amber tell us about neighbor
interactions yeah I am I've lived in my
neighborhood I click close to two years
now and it's so it's an actual
neighborhood with houses and families
and that's weird and great you don't
live like out in the middle of a dusty
field somewhere no but I for years I
lived in just like shitty apartment
buildings next to other shitty apartment
building so there weren't like yards and
houses and the same like people moved in
and out all the time so in theory I
could get to know all my neighbors but
that is yet to happen and I don't know
if that's an LA thing or like a society
as a whole thing or if it's a me being
antisocial thing but the same thing
happened to me when I moved in my house
I honestly expected like a Welcome Wagon
type of at least one or two people to
come and be like oh my god welcome and
because it's literally like almost a
cul-de-sac right and I only know ocular
doors
yeah it's just kind of like that they've
been driving just driving by me for ten
years yeah yeah yeah it's weird
but at the same time I don't know if I
super want to hang out with my neighbors
but so I might be the problem
but that said because I'm running now
I'm in my neighborhood more because that
wasn't of course you're not gonna meet
your neighbors you drive home you go
inside you close the door behind you you
and then you drop like you're never just
like hanging out in the front yard like
barbecuing or something there's no
instances where people are walking by
interacting but now that I'm running I
sort of am in the neighborhood and the
other morning it's probably 7 o'clock in
the morning I'm on my way back from the
run up you're running back are you're
walking back you're still running or no
I'm probably walking let's be honest
let's be real and and it's like 7 so but
I'm very awake at this point I've been
awake for a while and I already didn't
run and I why you'll see people outside
and some say good morning and some don't
I always like a good morning but then I
don't know it's weird I think you do you
ever do like like a Simpsons like a
a whole neighbor no but that would be
envoys I should start but it's also
weird because you can't be too warm in
your hellos too like creepy old man'll
alone because it feels like a weird
invitation which is a bummer but I like
this it is a good sex okay
so there'll be people outside with their
dogs or checking their mail and
sometimes they acknowledge you and
sometimes they don't and I'm okay with
either one but the other day I was
walking by and there was a girl standing
outside with a coffee cup and a dog no
real interaction and I'm I get three
step better or not I've been putting dog
[ __ ] in somebody else's trash I got
three steps away from her and she goes
amber I was legitimately startled
mmm-hmm because I did what's your name
it wasn't Rachel and I turn and I didn't
recognize this person but I don't know
how much I'm allowed to say at this part
this is the part where I'm that's the
end of the story I know her through a
project yes that I worked on very very
very incredibly briefly so I was
surprised that she even remembered me or
my name but and she was so out of it
like she initiated the interaction but
she was just like like every scent it
started I'm not exaggerating sorry I
just woke up like I was inconveniencing
her like like you went in and woke her
up in bed like hey you could have just
not said my name and then it felt rude
to leave but it also felt rude to stay
it was a strange breakfast together yeah
my new best friend but here's the one
thing that was funny when I got home
when I was like how did she know my name
had a long shot t-shirt I was wearing a
lot
I would have liked it if she was like
Shawn but but also what's weird is she
lives ten seconds away from me and has
for who knows how long and that's the
first time we've interacted two years
it's weird it's nice you know urban
urban life well these things will happen
when you live in a city
I really bought that at the beginning I
thought 170 something episode and never
has that been as soon as it starts I'm
like oh boy here we well we were talking
before about how ridiculous is
ridiculous
it is to not know your neighbors in a
city filled with earthquakes all the
time we're like I mean I I know people
who told stories of like the 94th quake
where they were like it mean all in the
street huddled together and doing all
this stuff or like during the riots or
whatever so I think about that all the
time just like and know to who to
account for like no I don't even know I
was missing exactly I know who has a gun
cabinet so when the [ __ ] goes down I
know where to go
same here and it's my crazy next-door
neighbor who's not that friendly and
likes to tell me what I need to be doing
with my lawn and fence and all that kind
of stuff but it's because he's an older
man and he's retired and doesn't have
anything he talks about wanting to kill
all the squirrels all the time like he's
that kind of a man but one time my ex
was over there in the back like in the
back alley helping it was something he
goes come in here and take a look at
this and he said it was like
bone-chilling they went into his garage
and it was just lined with guns just
like that guy in Fargo the gun cabinet
exactly but now I feel like a hundred
times calmer and safer and right now you
know where to go
yeah or avoid all right well this feels
like a good place to take a break so
let's do that and we will be back in a
moment with a segment on the show that
we like to call
party crews party so that was so from so
far away hey this is Sean Conroy you're
listening to the live chat podcast
this is what I sound like in real life
we rack you're listening to long shot
it's time for party cruise all right
let's start let's start today let's
start today with Amber all right and I'm
gonna close as I opened and go back to
Disneyland cuz I forgot about one
specific story the longest week we had
was for Space Mountain towards the end
of the night it was like an hour and a
half wait and at one point Jeff went to
get a bottle of water or something and
the girl in front of me in line just
starts talking to me and she was lovely
and she was saying that old preteen or
elderly I want to say like sixteen or
seventeen teen teen she just started
working at Disney it was her last day of
training that day and she picked the
wrong line to to stand in after her
shift and her first real shifts on
Sunday and she was nervous like it was
this like shut up for a second and let
me respond and to the point where when
Jeff came back he was like oh like am i
interrupting sorry that you guys are in
this I never even got her name but we
had this great conversation you should
find her on Facebook if you're listening
person no white [ __ ] a little bird on
her finger the whole time so again it
was a really long wait it was a hour and
a half is a long time I mean not really
in the middle of the week in September
we're not talking like summer peak
anyway
um we get to the front it's been an hour
and a half she looks at her phone and
goes my mom's here I have to go she
waited in line for one hour and a half
and skidaddled right before she got I
feel like she could have gone the bride
is not long like if she was at the front
of the line like go in the [ __ ] or
something about her and that move that
made her my hero in a weird way because
I'm an odd standards you went to the
ride from your mother
congratulations the
no because I think I would have just
been like sorry I didn't see the text
and like rode the ride does that make me
a terrible yeah be there in a sec I bet
her mom was terribly abusive maybe just
like right five across the eyes anytime
Dori just got terribly sad let's bring
it to the saddest place we can isn't
that what we're doing that's what it's
all about that's what party cruise is
well the party cruise guys ditched out
on how long that wait was at so many
periods hmm she just ducked through
didn't get the reward incredible party
cruise as in like like a boat a boat
have we ever done that what's your
question we've ever time my party cruise
yeah in all over your minds we're like
on a cruise right now no no maybe I did
the accent on it incorrectly party
cruise like as in the plural for a party
crew correct yes okay my head I'm
standing next to Tom Cruise had a party
oh yeah
so he's my part please then I want to
change mine to Penelope Cruz also be
standing next to some acquaintance Rod
Carew legendary angel there should be
children though so it's rod Carew's all
right I'll go next
and I'll tell you guys that I am broke
as [ __ ]
as usual why are we cursing I have no
[ __ ] money again no I I have it's to
me it's hilarious that I have a TV show
airing currently and I have no money but
my point is I went and took money out of
the longshots account at the bank this
week no no no it was on Saturday I said
do you know amber who works upstairs and
the woman was like I know amber put your
hands in the air
but what no the reason I bring it up is
because I think you guys should both do
it because it's a very empowering
feeling to go oh this thing that we've
been
working on four years can yield me
obviously has a tangible reward a lot of
money but what they say about me
they said you're lazy why do you always
were such big pants so no I'm
recommending that you guys go and take I
will take more from the bank because
it's like oh this is cool if I can cool
Karen parting shots I guess really what
I want to say and when I want to ruin to
be left with today is uh there was a
flood in the Trader Joe's the lemon Li's
I don't think it's lemons anymore this
Sun Dance sunset movie theater Center
right that Trader Joe's started flooding
today while I was in it because the
upstairs
crunch Jim was flooding its weren't a
severe drought the other day there was a
flood on Santa Monica did you see that
footage where it was literally waves of
water on Santa Monica crazy because they
pipe from 1914 burst I did hear that the
infrastructure the the the you know the
sewers and all that sort of stuff is
it's built to be replaced every three
hundred years no really it's not working
so we already don't have water and then
it just seems like every time I turn
around we're you have Leslie there's
things happening that don't need to be
happening so please when you brush your
teeth just turn turn the faucet on me I
know there's something weird about it
that like it feels like it's gonna
affect it or we got to do it because
apparently it's like gallons of you
saved gallons of water when you do that
you don't flush everything what do you
do if it's brown flush it down [ __ ] down
I just think that we're at this point
with this drought where everybody's like
not talking about it but it's really
severe right and then we're like when
that pipe burst I was like oh we're
about to flip into some weird
Mad Max area yeah because it's know
where the guns are month there was
another pipe that first on sunset
further west over three weeks ago UCLA
right yeah oh that one was like millions
of gallons of water - it's just it went
on for a couple days before they could
figure out oh that's not good we're
gonna die eventually we'll die soon just
I guess that's what I want people to end
up elderly great just thirsty alright
Jamie
parting shots my parting shot is this
that to ever talk about my grandma
calling Pat Sajak a fat cow I don't know
apparently he lived in the condo behind
her in Encino and just casually in a
conversation once like um Wheel of
Fortune came up or something and she was
like Pat Sajak that fat cow and it was
the funniest thing ever - ound like
casual conversation it was got Evan got
intense yeah point mm-hmm did you shake
her finger at you know she's a wonderful
grandma but she does have she's a
wonderful grandma I still feel like it's
very infantilizing for you to call her
your grandma what does he's was a
grandmother yeah that sounds so dope
like British yeah that's a little Lord
Fauntleroy should I say grandma my
cousins always called my great aunt and
a great uncle grandmother and
grandfather and it bothered me that
sounds like they're gonna kill you
goodnight may I have a cookie
grandmother yeah I just got confused as
to who was calling who what within the
family tree but then I realized it was
actually their grandparents mm-hmm not
your grandparents all right what else
Jamie to wrap up my portion I'm gonna
swing it over to you Karen to rewrap I'm
gonna ask you a question okay I love it
if you could distill down your personal
belief system okay yeah that was like
really putting somebody on us on the
spot I've been doing this I like it it
woke up parts of my brain that have been
dead for years I do have a personal if
you could say something that would
inspire our listeners in some way
something that helps you get through
every day mm-hmm some sort of distilled
down nugget of truth
I mean guiding principle always helps
guiding principle it can be a quote it
could just be a hey hey situation free
team you know a like no I will tell you
I once read a card that stayed with me
for a long time which was no matter what
happens to you or how like I'm I'm very
badly paraphrasing this right now but
like whatever happens you embarrassments
or hideous public shames or whatever
terrible thing that you feel everyone
knows about you there are 2.2 billion
Chinese people who have no idea who you
are choosing moved to China if you're
too embarrassed no then you'll be
embarrassed you just can you can just
remember that in in reality no one gives
two shits about what you're doing
because everyone's so embarrassed about
themselves so you can just let it go
that's great
mm-hmm thank you yeah Karen thank you so
much for being here can people find you
on Twitter they can find me on Twitter
at Karen Kohl Gareth okay and what about
your website I just got yelled at
mallesh I did show by - I would say
girls did we do did we talk about people
in their mid-20s no no everything no I
met two great hilarious girls at the
Bell House I did a couple shows for
Eugene Mirman
Comedy Festival and they both asked me
if I had a pod a website and then when I
told them I didn't they got really mad
at me and we're like get up get up
website why would you not have a website
I was like well I'm on Twitter
everything's on there anyway I do have a
podcast though do you need a ride with
Chris Fairbanks that's also on the all
things comedy network that we're on
right now and what about you have like
an album or something I do I have a live
album that came out last year I think or
recorded it last year called live at the
bootleg that's my comedy songs that I
like to do so awesome and soon she'll be
headlining at the world-famous Hollywood
him oh yeah that's right I get to do a
caracal garrison friends very very
excited about that
Karen was on the last liquid feet show
it was awesome yeah that was a great job
that was very calm all right well thank
you so much for being here absolutely my
pleasure this has been the longshot
we'll see you next time
now we're gonna go the beep different
names who papyrus
for past and future episodes of the
longshots podcast
join us online at the longshot podcast
calm